it does seem like the span between
tragedy coming across the iphone and
partisan response is getting down to
mere seconds
i mean this is the second time in i
think seven days that i've been on your
show
both of which have had incredibly
heinous and horrific tragedies
immediately followed by
naked exploitation of the dead bodies
before
anything is known about the people
involved including
the killer you know i was watching joe
biden i empathize so much with what will
said that
at the beginning of his speech i was
really hoping that he would strike
exactly that notice somebody who has
twice had to bury a child he could
really empathize with in a unique way
with how uniquely heinous it is he could
talk about the spirituality of our
society and the need to
unite on on what obviously everyone no
matter what your partisan perspective is
reacting the same way when seeing this
sort of thing and he spent about six
seconds doing that and then immediately
did a detour to figure out how he could
squeeze and exploit the situation for
partisan advantage it was so grotesque
and i mean unsurprising but also really
disappointing to watch
and as god watches speaking for myself i
would have praised joe biden if he had
kept to the first part of that speech i
agree with you completely joe biden has
lost two children not many people can
say that he knows what it feels like i
would listen carefully to him and i
would feel deeply grateful if he used
this moment to unite the country we all
are united in our grief as we watched
children die
why not do that
i mean
i think that the
obsession that people who are doing
politics full time have with seeing the
war the world through this prism of
partisan warfare is so consuming that it
basically drains their entire soul so
that nothing is left but this kind of
immediate need to
use every situation no matter how tragic
to gain some kind of an advantage and
look you know joe biden is a politician
he's in public policy there are public
policy aspects events like this or the
one in buffalo so if you want to talk
about that that's fine
wait a little bit of time not just that
the emotions can be processed but so
that just basic facts are known about
who this person is what motivated them
what guns what role guns had in terms of
gun control laws or anything else you
want to talk about they don't wait at
all because they want to exploit those
emotions that they could be using to
unite people to instead work them to
their own advantage it's so ghoulish and
grotesque to watch it really is people
have died and we owe them the respect of
restraint that's how i feel about all
death uh and i know you agree this stuff
just drains people's humanity and it's
just awful glenn greenwald thank you for
your description of that
thanks tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight